[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing tom riddle horcruxes called
voldemort and the properties of dark
magic more specifically we're going to
be discussing the ravaging effects that
horcruxes had on tom riddle both on his
appearance and on his soul what truly
prompted him to become voldemort and
what happened to his nose how did he go
from possessing human features to
snake-like features and eventually no
recognizable features at all in the
half-blood prince harry gasps at what
becomes of the once handsome tom riddle
entirely unsure of what he has become
harry let out a hastily stifled gasp
voldemort had entered the room his
features were not those that harry had
seen emerge from the great stone
cauldron almost two years ago they were
not as snake-like the eyes were not yet
scarlet the face not yet mask-like and
yet he was no longer handsome tom riddle
it was as though his features had been
burned and blurred they were waxy and
oddly distorted and the whites of the
eyes now had a permanently bloody look
though the pupils were not yet the slits
that harry knew they would become he was
wearing a long black cloak and his face
was as pale as the snow glistening on
his shoulders let's dive into the
destruction of voldemort before we get
started let's just clear up exactly what
a horcrux is since they're pretty vital
to the rest of the video essentially the
horcrux is an object in which a dark
witch or wizard has imbued part of their
soul the purpose of which is to achieve
immortality well you split your soul you
see and hide part of it in an object
outside the body then even if one's body
is attacked or destroyed one cannot die
for part of the soul remains earthbound
and undamaged horcruxes were considered
to be one of the most vile pieces of
dark magic and the very topic of a
horcrux was so taboo that very few
witches and wizards even in the darkest
sphere ever even knew of their existence
those who did know on the other hand
were smart enough not to discuss them
any further well i guess with the
exception of horus loghorn
books dedicated to dark magic like magik
most evil blatantly refused to speak on
horcruxes which should be a testament to
just how bad they were of the horcrux
wickedest of magical inventions we shall
not speak nor give direction in fact the
only book in the wizarding world with
any kind of proper information on
horcruxes was a book entitled secrets of
the darkest art which was hidden away in
dumbledore's office
the book bound in faded black leather
with accents of purple gave explicit
instructions on how horcruxes were made
how to destroy them and how creating one
can affect you the book however only
discusses the consequences of creating
one horcrux and in this respect
voldemort took things much further in
this regard voldemort's achievements and
the various outcomes good and bad that
came from creating multiple horcruxes
were entirely unprecedented no one could
have recently predicted what horcrux
creation would have done to his body and
mind as it had never been done in this
sort of scale before this brings us to
the young impressionable tom riddle the
orphan that tragically never quite stood
the chance in the half blood prince were
taken all the way back to 1938 where we
see a much younger sprayer dumbledore
visiting a troubled looking young boy in
an orphanage who is sitting alone in the
corner of the room other than an
uncomfortable looking expression on his
face no doubt concealing a myriad of
emotions he looked like any other little
boy and would have blended right in with
the other orphans to any kind of
passerby at least that would be your
first impression but if you stuck around
for any reasonable amount of time you
would have seen first hand that young
tom riddle was not like the other
children and i'm not just talking about
the fact that he was magical you see
young tom loved to torment the other
orphans he was an exceedingly hostile
young boy processing and concealing all
sorts of emotions and inner turmoil that
the rest of the world knew not tom
himself didn't understand what was wrong
with him but he always knew he was
different and he knew that he needed to
make an impression on the world after
his introduction to dumbledore he's
invited to hogwarts school where he
quickly becomes a shining pupil an
innately talented wizard with a passion
for knowledge all driven by the pursuit
for power after spending some time at
hogwarts a young tom riddle would
eventually come to befriend professor
horus loghorn riddles then potions
professor slughorn had a tendency to
choose favorites from his classes he'd a
keen eye for identifying if someone
would go on to achieve greatness in some
capacity and would always take great
pride in their accomplishments usually
at least if you were close with zoghorn
he would tell you anything and that's
probably why on one occasion after just
the right amount of manipulation and
flattery from riddle he provided him
with pivotal information on horcruxes
the very form of magic that was
instrumental in voldemort's rise to
power this was the beginning of the end
for riddle as from this point onward he
now possessed the necessary information
to curse his soul mind and body all in
the needless pursuit of power with this
new information riddle embarked on his
journey of creating horcruxes and from
that moment on he started to dehumanize
himself both physically and mentally
gradually slipping and moving even
further away from the man that he once
was because of his horcruxes voldemort
couldn't die he was tethered to the
world through these objects but that
certainly didn't mean that voldemort was
truly alive he had a cursed existence i
believe that voldemort is now so
immersed in evil and these crucial parts
of himself have been detached for so
long he does not feel as we do so what
exactly does dark magic do to you why
does it change your appearance what
happened to voldemort well in essence
voldemort's appearance changed because
of the actions that he undertook every
time he murdered someone every time he
cast unforgivable curses and every time
he created the horcrux he tore his soul
apart even further which made him become
less human and more monster it wasn't
just horcrux as it altered tom riddle it
was a combination of everything living
in evil existence with nothing but the
wrong intentions voldemort didn't turn
into the monster that he was overnight
at least not physically it was a gradual
process that occurred over years
performing dark deeds for example there
was a moment where dumbledore shows
harry a memory of voldemort after he
resurfaced this was after he disappeared
for ten years he came back to hogwarts
to hide the ravenclaw horcrux and to ask
dumbledore who was newly appointed as
headmaster for the defense against a
dark arts position at this point it's
made clear that tom riddle's appearance
had drastically changed no he wasn't
white-skinned with no nose but he wasn't
the handsome boy that he once was he'd
clearly begun to spiral down the dark
descent into the unnatural horrors that
dark magic can bring basically with each
horcrux that he created voldemort became
paler more snake-like and less human
dumbledore felt that one of the main
contributing factors in the degradation
of his appearance was the damage that he
had done to his soul yet it fitted lord
voldemort had seemed to grow less human
with the passing years and the
transformation he had undergone seemed
to me to be only explicable if his soul
was mutilated beyond the realms of what
we might call usual evil and we see a
perfect example of this in the afterlife
after harry's encounter with voldemort
in the forbidden forest harry turned
slowly on the spot his surroundings
seemed to invent themselves before his
eyes he had spotted the thing that was
making the noises it had the form of a
small naked child curled on the ground
its skin raw and rough flayed looking
and it lay shuddering under a seat where
it had been left unwanted stuffed out of
sight struggling for breath harry was
met with the last piece of soul that
voldemort possessed a damaged tormented
representation of what dark magic can do
to a person voldemort lived a cursed
life where he would routinely rip his
own soul apart in pursuit of immortality
and such acts come at a great cost the
pathetic wriggling child squirming along
the floor was all that was left of
voldemort's soul in conclusion there's
no one spell or one action that one can
take in order to change their appearance
in the way that voldemort did it takes a
lifetime of dedication to dark arts and
dark deeds that's the only way one could
possibly expect to recreate the
unprecedented horrors achieved by lord
voldemort and that's it for this video
if you enjoyed the content please like
the video and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember for in dreams
we enter a world that is entirely our
own
[Music]